Cool.
We are set
Good enough.
Uh, we're going to see how long this
stream is.
Not entirely sure yet.
Let me set myself up one small thing on
the side.
And uh, we have at least we did get a
sweep out of this yesterday. I don't
know how much those prams are going to
transfer. We shall see. I'm seeing
pretty high entropy.
Stuff doesn't look too crazy, honestly.
We'll see how that goes.
Uh,
how am I going to do this?
One second.
Get rid of a bunch of crap real quick.
I think we're good.
Hey, Arch.
Hey, Alec.
Um,
So, apparently these are good params. We
shall see.
algo solved. You know, I actually I did
come up with something good yesterday.
It's a much simpler algorithm.
Um
I'm going to So, I'm going to try it.
We're going to commit this.
I'm going to try out
very quickly. Okay, I'm going to try
this first
and we're going to make sure that this
repros
It's funny that we get a different gamma
and lambda
for the horizon.
So, I basically did a restricted sweep
where uh I didn't let it set. Like I
know that you can do better on this by
making the network gigantic
or by cranking up replay ratios. I
didn't want it to do that.
I believe some of these params are dead
as well.
Wait. 5 E8. So that's 500 mil.
But wait, we'll give it one bill then.
And we don't have to worry about the um
LR decay either, which is nice.
Allock, you're doing the wrong thing.
All right, look, grab like default
abuntu
and then stop worrying about your dro
and spend your time on programming.
Learn a couple basic CLI tools, but like
all the other like ricing and dro
hopping, it's all just meme.
This is in my guide actually. If you
read my programming in ML guide, that's
in my advice for beginners. So, reread
that.
Ooh, unstable. Interesting. A little
unstable.
Like ultimately the thing that matters
is having working knowledge of a variety
of areas of programming. That's the
thing that matters.
Not DRO hopping all over the place and
whatever.
Not using advantage anymore. No, it's
not using uncertainty yet. This one here
is just using episode return. Um, I have
another algorithm that we're going to do
today that will be better.
It's actually pretty similar to what we
have here. It should be more stable
though. Hey, Call
just for a single choice.
Like grab default Auntu whatever it is.
24 or 25 now and just call it a day.
Like realistically, the only setting
that I think that uh programmers
absolutely need to have
that I see people forget to do is you
need to increase your or decrease your
key press delay so you can actually like
type at a reasonable speed and navigate
around with your navigate around with
your arrows or your um Vim keys.
That's it.
Okay, cool. Very unstable. Very good.
Very, very fun game. Um,
we're going to treat this as
Envim is fun. You don't have to go learn
every possible thing about it though.
Like again, it's kind of meme.
Like Envim is nice because it's simple,
it's lightweight, and it doesn't tie you
to a bloated IDE that's going to like
you're going to spend forever debugging.
You'll notice I haven't messed with my
setup in a long time.
Um, yeah, the progress. I'll explain the
new algorithm in a second. I'm just
trying to think where I want to start
from.
New branch probably.
Uhoh.
Internet.
Just my SSH flipping. Let me go grab the
diagram that I drew.
right,
new algorithm is well getting filtered
out by the face detector but much
simpler. There.
I'm a little tired today. Let me see if
I do it this way.
DSE
are asking me to pick E. Why the hell
are they doing that?
Like, what are you interested in, man?
Do you like doing a [ __ ] ton of math?
do like like what do you what do you do?
Hey Jess. Uh yeah, major changes to the
algorithm. I took a nice long walk
yesterday. I sat upstairs uh in the sun,
got myself uh just had some time to
think. I drew up some plans, which we're
going to do now.
overview. Yeah,
I don't mind the Flappy Bird PRs, Jess.
Eventually, we're going to accept one of
them that's like nice and high quality
at some point. It's because it's the um
it's the suggested default project if
you just don't know what to build in the
guide.
I'm waiting for the right one where
somebody comes onto the stream and says
like, "Hey, you know, I'm new. Um, I
built this Flappy Bird and I did it like
mostly manually or fully manually. Um, I
put some time into it. I'm looking for a
review. I know it's a simple end, but I
thought think this is like a good
starting point and I'd really appreciate
a like if I get something like that,
then I will go review a Flappy Bird and
merge it
This is kind of lazy, but hopefully this
is good enough. We'll see.
okay. So, here's the the algorithm,
right? The very simple version of this
is just for a certain number of seeds,
store the best recorded trajectory. Some
environments are devoted to samp uh
starting from points along that
trajectory to robustify
and some M are devoted to just trying to
find better trajectories. Some M's are
devoted to your normal PO. This is
basically just the simplest possible way
to make use of state sets. Um, it fixes
a bunch of the problems with the
previous algorithm. It should be very
robust. It should work. We will see from
here.
Whatever. It's fine.
The good news is that this algorithm
will be simple enough that this will
legitimately end up being like a few
hundred lines of code. Um,
so this will actually be even easier
than before for me to like manually
fix once we have the result.
Dario just published. Um,
uh, yes, we had
way ahead of you, my guy.
Co-signed.
It's funny. He actually saw it.
All right, we actually have to read this
and revise now. That's very funny.
reward only trajectory buffer
split m each roll out.
How the hell are you seriously asking me
that question, dude, when they're like
not letting you use their [ __ ] models
for AI research? Only we get to use the
model for AI research. Like, they can
kindly just go [ __ ] themselves and it's
very simple. That's why we have the
whole thing up there.
Like I knew a couple of the people that
were on the first like few to join
Anthropic and they were batshit insane.
It hasn't gotten any better since.
It's just the most out of touch AI
people in SF which is the most outofouch
city in the world.
Exactly.
Well, actually, Jess, I think the
difference is OpenAI knew that they were
[ __ ] Um, these people are dumb
enough to believe their own like their
own argument, though.
How are you down sampling?
Yeah. So, Arch's configurable.
No, no, no, no, no. It would be like,
you know, one state per like two or four
or eight or 16 states.
It's not going to be like per horizon.
That's way too sparse.
No idea the memory constraint.
Yeah, the memory is going to be a little
annoying. Arch.
Um,
it is CPU RAM. It's not VRAM. So, I
think that we should be fine.
States.
Is there any waiting that's going to
occur for states
initially? No. That is where you could
potentially use advantage, but the
problem with advantage is you have to
refresh it. And refreshing advantage is
annoying.
See you, Jess.
You have to change the title. I did
change the title, didn't I?
Simpler state set algorithm for 5.0.
Super excited to mess around with
puffer. Welcome.
um, there will be more interesting
content soon. I've sort of been stuck on
the 5.0 algorithm for a while, so my
head's a little bit fuzzy from thinking
about all sorts of stuff there.
But essentially the idea is that we've
got uh the idea around here is we have a
bunch of people working on M's that are
newer. Um some people who are more
experienced working on more complicated
Ms. Some of those people have then moved
on to help with algorithm and core
stuff. And I at the moment am working on
a new algorithm that leverages the
ability to restore the state of an
environment to any previously seen state
which is very easy to implement and it's
mostly a a question of algorithmic
details. So that's what I'm working on
at the moment. I've been working on that
for a few weeks. Uh I came up with
something that should be pretty
straightforward and should work
yesterday. We're going to try that today
and we're going to see how that works.
And then hopefully I'm going to be able
to stop just typing crap into codecs
very soon and I'm actually going to be
able to like manually fix and
reimplement the thing as soon as I have
a couple decent experiments.
That's what's going on here.
Hey, Hayden. Welcome.
What are you doing it in? Are you just
doing it in the sea? If it's fast,
that's um that'll be pretty darn nice as
an N. I'd love to have N pendulums.
Just have the cartpole end with the
exact cartpole dynamics, but if you just
set N, it just gives you more pendulums.
That'd be cool.
Purple length.
Purple N.
Thanks, Liberty. I am very tired from
the last few weeks, to be honest.
The uh crazy psychotic cut I've been on
is not helping. I think today I'm going
to try to get myself a
bit more protein in in a couple of hours
and we'll see if that helps. It is very
fuzzy.
Part rope at that point. I think you
have to make the poles longer. I think
the problem is people making the poles
too short and then you're basically
Yeah, you can't balance a rope. Modified
double pendulum. So, I got it cleaned
up. Yeah. Yeah, of course. Like, we'd
want it to be a cleaned PR. You tried
the other reward and stuff, right,
Hayden? Plus sweeps.
I'm guessing that's pretty much all
Yasine did as well.
It's possible that you might have to
expand the action space. Um, you know,
the left right might have to be more
precise.
It worked great. Good. I've never even
tested that, by the way. I sort of just
came up with that cuz we use similar
rewards on other problems. that deltat
base formulation is very important to
understand. Um actually this we'll make
this an educational
making a docs lovely. Um so we'll we'll
make this a little bit of an educational
piece here. So the reason um that I
suggested that reward which to be clear
I suggested that the reward for
balancing multiple pendulums should be
from one step to the next the change in
height of the highest point of the
pendulum. And uh the way the reason that
I suggested that specific delta
formulation instead of just reward for
max height or something like that is
that using this type of delta reward
encourages you to get closer to the
goal. It doesn't encourage you to like
stay just a little bit away from the
goal. It penalizes you for getting
farther away. It's not reward hackable.
Um there are many instances I don't know
if in this specific case but there are
many instances where having a dense
reward that looks like you know uh more
reward for distance to goal or whatever
can be hackable. And uh it's also
numerically it's very difficult to
distinguish one from the other because
you'll typically get like high reward as
you get closer and closer but the
difference in reward is very small um
from one state to the next. It sort of
gets washed out. So you get both better
conditioned rewards with deltas and also
you remove a lot of potential for reward
hacking. So we use this on a lot of
problems including professionally. It
works quite well and I think a lot of
the robotics rewards would work way
better with this. In fact, I actually
found a bug with the rewards where they
were hackable in a popular robotics
library one time and then they said, "Oh
no, this is intentional because of this
other thing." And what they'd
essentially done is they'd changed their
advantage calculation to also have
another bug such that the two bugs
cancel each other out.
Um, but the best thing is really just to
use delta base rewards when you can.
Somebody said they got eight pendulums
with like longer pendulums or whatever
on X. I don't know if I believe them. A
lot of the people trying this stuff are
just like straight vibe coding the thing
intend which is not going to work. Um,
you can probably like vibe the like vibe
code the stupid environment and maybe
force something to work. Yeah, that I
believe. But the whole learning dynamics
that's not going to work because puffer
is not just po. It's substantially more
sophisticated.
I actually don't even know who the hell
that was to be honest.
I think I just because I posted my thing
publicly, you know, the defense.
I didn't notice while I was giving the
defense. Honestly, I wouldn't be
surprised that all the comments about
that are what let the thing blow up in
the algorithm anyways.
But ah, whatever.
I have so much cooler stuff in the last
few years
since my PhD.
I mean, the amount of progress since
then is nuts. I would not believe the
stuff that we have today, three years
ago.
In fact, looking back, it was kind of
insane that I was excited as I was about
like trying to actually make RL work.
Um,
just with the knowledge that I like the
lack of knowledge that I had back then,
it was pretty objectively nuts to try to
do the stuff I was doing with Puffer and
it just kind of worked.
So, sometimes you don't have to be
smart, you just have to be kind of uh
obsessive.
I start puffer right after I graduated
about three years ago.
It really just started as a um like a
compatibility layer to make it easier to
work with all the fancy environments out
there. And then the Perf thing sort of
just started happening. Like we kind of
just started seeing all the places where
stuff was bad and slowly replacing them.
And then in the last year or so, we kind
of just got to the point where we said,
"Okay, our own stuff is better. There's
no need to rely on any third party
anything anymore. And we just replaced
Everything.
What are we doing here?
The whole implementation. Great.
Don't try this at home. I'm a
professional.
None of that code's getting kept in uh
in Puffer 5. Don't worry.
This is basically me just like hacking
on algorithm, seeing if I can get some
valid experiments and then from there I
will actually write it. It'll be fun.
I thought about this one for a while.
It's like kind of unprofessional and
blah blah blah, but that's the correct
response.
Why it may be a bad idea to enal entropy
coefficient?
Well, you're assuming that the final
policy can have zero entropy. So, you
basically can just collapse it to be
deterministic too early.
I also think deterministic policies are
much more brittle because like one small
change that screws with the actions they
can be less robust.
Um actually here I have a I do have a
theory on that. Hang on
here. So let me let me just give you
this uh we can get rid of that. Okay. So
here's the theory, right?
So let's say that you have a trajectory
like you have to go around some
obstacles or whatever
and then this is the optimal
trajectory to get to the target.
Right?
So when you have some entropy, you're
going to also occasionally you're going
to go to like here and then you're going
to have to go like this or you're going
to end up here and then you're going to
have to go like this. Right? So if you
get off the trajectory, you're fine. But
with no entropy, if you have a
deterministic policy, this is all you
know. So I think that as soon as you get
to like as soon as by some chance you
get to here, like you're just screwed.
You don't know how to get back because
you only know this one path. And again,
it depends on the environment. I don't
think it's as bad in um PCGNs where like
you get robustness anyways. But uh I can
definitely see cases where having the
policy collapse even if the solution is
deterministic is very bad for
robustness.
Oh, wait. Hang on. Experimented with
cosign and kneeling.
It seems to work on breakout. I missed
your first message. Did you improve the
um the solve time?
I would believe that you can enneal it
from a high thing down to like a lower
point that's not zero. Well,
more easily and stays there.
Just playing around. Uh, breakout's a
good end for playing around with it.
You're going to want to try it on some
harder tasks eventually, though. I think
that the only thing that's like a pretty
good meaningful indicator on breakout is
if you improve the speed run time,
like substantially. If you get a 2
second breakout solve down from 4
seconds for instance, I will be very
interested.
Even that is not going to be a uh a
guarantee on anything.
When new article article on what on the
new algorithm when I actually have it
working and integrated and like solving
stuff in Puffer 5.
The last uh few weeks have been somewhat
disappointing, I would say.
Well, the key error assumption that I
made in um in the Puffer 5 algorithm
that I came up with to be fair, I don't
think it's one that any researcher in
the world would have caught from my
initial description of it. So, it wasn't
like a totally stupid error. Um I wish
I'd caught it after a week or a week and
a half instead of three weeks, but it
happens. And I think we have a new
algorithm from it. And I'm even more
confident that this will work now. So
should be good.
Any deadlines? No. That is one of the
nice things about having my own company.
I do not have deadlines. Um
research under deadlines is very very
bad. The only thing that we have for
this update is uh no scope creep. So I'm
not going to creep the scope of puffer 5
to be a big update. I want it to be a
very small concentrated update on uh the
new algorithm.
So pretty much whenever I have something
that is stable with state sets and
generally useful then I will like I will
push that as the next update.
If we finish it early then I will
consider adding a few small things.
Would an LLM have caught it faster? No.
In fact, the LLM did not provide a
single useful idea in the entirety of
the last three weeks. These things are
[ __ ]
They sometimes can implement shitty
prototype code more quickly than I can
uh or
when I'm too tired to do so myself. And
that is about it.
The key error arch was me not realizing.
So the key difference is that go explore
and these other state-based algorithms
they use uncertainty as a metric and
when you find something that is
uncertain you keep going you explore
from there and you find more things that
are uncertain. The problem is advantage
works the other way. So like you find a
lucky state that seems that it has high
advantage and then you have to go
backwards to how you got there in order
to learn that trajectory and that is
very difficult to do with the type of
state set algorithm that this was
inspired by.
Yeah, you can't go forward with
advantage. And the thing is even if you
go backwards with advantage, it's very
hard to like to refresh your advantage
estimate
on a trajectory. It's very difficult to
refresh it.
So it's quite annoying
because advantage is an on policy
estimate as well.
How hard would the masters be today if
it's not?
Well, I mean, it depends on that depends
massively on your situation, right?
So for somebody in my situation, it
would be batshit. If that's your way to
get to the US,
like maybe it's worth it. I don't know.
I at least think I don't think that the
education provided by a master's is
worth it. Let's put it that way.
That make sense or should I not be?
Yeah, I think actually you just want it
to be this way, right?
Yeah, you can't refresh advantage. The
policy is already updated and it's off
policy. Yeah, exactly. So, it's kind of
subtle, right? It's the combination of
you have to go backwards, which is
already sort of annoying to implement,
and then there's not really a good way
to refresh it because keep in mind, the
whole point of the advantage in these
sparse ends is that you find a rare
event. So like in order to get an active
advantage estimate, you'd basically have
to go all the way back to the start and
then do a ton of rollouts
um to get like a good estimate of it.
It's just not and it's very noisy even
then like advantage since it's a learned
metric like you can end up kicking out
good segments by advantage as well. So
there really were just a ton of problems
with it and um the key key realization
right is that uh it is a bad idea to
stick stuff into the buffer that has
higher episode return. But I do think
that the trajectory refinement thing
from Go Explore is correct. And given
that we can't really do something
segment based on advantage, I think this
is the
other thing that will work. And it's
much simpler as
What?
This is the most out of touch possible
thing. The reason that people are
worried about AI is because the uh the
AI CEOs are like glorified cigarette ad
agency execs.
Bunch of bastards.
They don't need more optimistic AI CEOs.
They need AI CEOs that aren't total
bastards.
Oo,
this is very nice.
Thank you.
Very nice puffer.
Uh 25 22% end of time is a little bit
concerning here.
1.2 mil SPS
with a 1 mil perm policy.
Hm.
Did he meaningfully progress from his
starting point? Uh, yes. Yes, Selby. I
think he kind of stopped doing a lot of
the heavy M work a while ago, but from
like not knowing anything to having done
Enduro, and this was before you could
just vibe code everything as well. Um,
that was a lot of stuff learned. Also,
all the stuff he did on Pokémon, he
definitely progressed meaningfully.
And as you'd know as well, Spencer, who
I now work with uh professionally, he
also started not knowing anything about
RL. His first NPR was absolutely
terrible code.
And uh I now take him over like most if
not almost all MIT PhD grads. Well,
actually I think it's more accurate to
say I don't know a single other MIT PhD
grad I'd rather have than Spencer.
That's even a stronger endorsement.
Like I know a couple people that are
better at the core RL than him, but not
many.
Especially the practical like get the
thing to work on new problem. he's very
good at
and he's been catching up on the
research background as well.
Like his self-play stuff is quite solid.
That project with Jess,
it's pretty much just like the crazy
obscure stuff that you just need a
decade of experience that I have to help
with occasionally.
This was pretty funny. He asked like
who's doing the eight pend like seven
pendulum and I just said you now and he
actually started doing it.
That's all it takes. That was like
yesterday, right?
It was like who's doing it? You right
now. I'll get going.
This can be you folks.
Like
just go to the site, read our literally
one page of docs. This is all there is.
Grab the tutorial and get started. And
also star the puffer. It helps us a lot.
The puffer star and get help. He likes
stars. Look, I literally I made so many
tutorial ends about puffer fish eating
stars. You see these puffers eating
stars? If this doesn't get you to start
the repo, I don't know what does. Nom
nom nom nom nom.
Ever too late to start? No, of course
not.
Honestly, the only thing that's like
tough is when you just have too many
damn obligations to have time to devote.
That's what people mean by too late to
start. It's that you've just accumulated
too much crap in your life to have time
to do things that you actually want to
do.
You know, I say no to lots of things so
that I don't have that problem.
I should just read the config. That's
being lazy.
that would be mine. and codeex. I
already did that.
research paper pan out. Well, I still
don't know whether their comparison is
fair.
It gives me some ideas though.
very slow.
Okay, we'll try this.
Little time steps is one bill. 3 minute
runs are way better than yesterday.
research can probably tune go explore
hypers much better. Um well I would
believe you can beat go explore. Go
explore is basically just the simplest
state set algorithm you can do given
access to a novelty metric of some type.
The tree search paper it's just like
let's use R&D instead of cell sets
right. Um, and then instead of just
picking random states, they're doing a
like they're keeping a tree. So, I would
believe that's going to be much more
efficient.
That said, they also like the task that
these types of papers are choosing,
they're choosing the best possible task
for their case.
We also should be able to get this to be
faster.
Work on that as well.
Yeah. So we got eight score which is
very bad.
We can take these out for now.
They're going to be less relevant, I'm
sure.
So um the new algorithm is essentially
just like keep the best trajec well for
the purpose of so it's a little
different generally but you just keep
the best trajectory that you've seen so
far and then you get to set some of the
end states to be randomly on that
trajectory.
Where?
Damn. What the heck is wrong with
keyboard
one there?
What's the best way to start
experimenting
with RL?
Uh, check the docs on Puffer.
Grab one of the template environments.
Go mess around with it. Like two 300
lines of code for a basic starter end. I
also have guides on my X
X.com/juarez.
My beginner guide for ML and
programming. And if you're more
experienced, my uh ultra opinionated
guide to RL. Those are my two best
pieces of educational content.
Okay, this is interesting. So, we have a
length 709
to five.
Interesting.
What's the best paper to read?
You really don't need to read a paper
initially for puffer. Um, I have several
papers linked in that RL guide. It's
kind of spaced out naturally for you.
So, you get to do some stuff and then
read a little and do some stuff and read
a little. I would just follow the stuff
that I've suggested in that like the
ultra opinionated RL guide. basically
all of my best thoughts in one spot in a
pretty compact read. And you're also
you're not meant to read that thing from
the start to finish. You're kind of
meant to work through it. It gives you
stuff to do.
Hang on.
I can just like guess, can I?
Fresh rack 0.5.
No 75. Let's do point
0.3
five.
Let's do like this.
Reverse.
Reor Ford curriculum.
Uh, do you have a paper? What's the
name?
Like they're a million towels.
How are you so smart, bro? I'm really
not
like being me does not feel smart. It
feels like miraculously the things I'm
working on are being done ludicrously
incompetently for no apparent [ __ ]
reason.
Like it's not very complicated to say,
"Hey guys, um, computers could run this
thing at maybe 20 million steps per
second. Why does our Python program run
this at 10 steps per second?"
Like it's a pretty simple, manageable
question, right?
Heck of the envelope. We could probably
run this 20 million steps per second.
Why does it run at 10?
stone. Yeah, I know. Stone. Oh, this
one. Yeah. Yeah. Cool.
offline demos? I see. Yeah. So
different.
Very different in that case.
But I would believe Yeah. Stone Stone
generally has very good work. So, it
makes sense that he's thinking about
this type of stuff.
I've read the Manny skill code base,
chunks of it. It's good for robotics,
but robotics is just Man, they need some
help with their code.
Runescape made you so consistent. It's
funny that you mentioned that. Uh, what
are we at? 94 herblore.
This gets stuck for just a very long
time.
Nicest 4K dedicated. Uh, so my setup
here is I have I think two 27inch 4Ks
and my main one that I'm doing all my
work on is right in front of me and then
the stream monitor is a vertical one and
it's just basically it's just on like
the bottom third of my screen there and
then I have OBS there and anything
private that I need to have, you know,
email or whatever.
Honestly, the whole idea for my PhD and
all the stuff, it all came from
Runescape. Like it's not just oh what if
Runescape like the tick system of that
game and the way that MMOs optimized
complex interesting gameplay mechanics
to run on '90s hardware with thousands
of players like that was the key to
I mean that's the whole key to RL right
is how do you get interesting simulation
that runs ludicrously fast that's
already been solved for us by MMOs
If you check in the Discord, we actually
have some really cool results on like
simulated Runescape type environments.
Um, Valo's been working on that. John's
been working on that.
Lots and lots of cool code has been
submitted there.
I actually didn't um I didn't really
play Runescape growing up. I played a
French MMO called Dophus, which is
basically tactical fantasy chess on
steroids. I found Runescape in college.
I played it like a couple times when I
was younger, but not really much at all.
But um you know, I played a bunch of
different MMOs. MMOs were always the my
favorite genre. I really like the open
world, the really long-term progression,
the ability to like strategize on how
you're going to approach like the ne not
the next 20 minute game, but the next
100 hours of content.
I don't know. It's always been very cool
to me.
I'm not I don't play 5D chess, man. I'm
playing [ __ ] checkers here.
I've had very many weird interactions
with people because they think I have
like some crazy I'm playing checkers.
This is not considered working hard what
I'm doing here. This is considered being
very lazy. Puffer four. That was hard
work.
Do we just have super jank params or
something?
We do, don't we?
Google research football and um
we had discussions of similar things. Uh
I don't think that's actually worth
doing believe it or not. I think that we
would just build our own.
like their env is going to be too slow
is my guess. And even if it's not, it's
going to be super heavy.
Temple OS, I'm not that far out there,
am I?
I mean, Puffer is like the core of
Puffer is 5K lines of code. It's really
tight.
And actually, I think it could be more
like three or 4K. That's just me being
bad at CUDA.
Like I have to just learn some more
CUDA.
It's a little annoying cuz we're still
the algorithm is still in flux. I'm
hoping once the algorithm is
solid by which I'll define the algorithm
being solid as like yes we could improve
things but for every one of those like
dumb pathological examples where the RL
should work but doesn't the RL works and
for all of our hard ends where we think
it should work under good hypers and
stuff it does work like once we have it
just nice and stable feeling across the
board it's 80% of the way already
That's probably when I will just take
some time to really really polish.
Wow, there's a skill.md for my own repo,
the own my own project. I'm sure I
should be using that.
I read that thing for the for the LOLs.
It's literally like a not entirely
correct version of the docs that they
had an LLM generate without actually
seeing the source or the docs.
Mind-bogglingly stupid things.
I mean like
can we just go through the logic that it
takes to think that this is a good idea?
Just the number of levels of stupidity
that this takes. Okay, so I have docs.
Okay, and I have precise example code.
Um, so imagine getting an LLM, having it
generate a summary of Puffer without
reading my nice docs, without reading my
nice sample code and stuff, having it
just spit something out that's
completely inaccurate, and then feeding
that to another LLM in order to like
understand the project for you and
implement stuff.
You see, I'm not a genius.
I just point out things that are
obviously stupid.
Like there are a couple clever things in
a few bits of the puffer architecture
and stuff, but that's about it.
basically same properties are random.
Yeah, I that's what it looked like. Arch
um which that should be good news,
right?
that it's like it ends up being very
similar to something from one of the
very very short list of people that I
know actually do consistently good work.
Now look, obviously there is a very
large difference between it being a demo
and having to get it yourself
because you end up with this whole
design space of like do I use advantage,
do I use this, do I do that? How do I
get the actual trajectory?
And I've spent the last few weeks
exploring that. And now I have
now I have a more nuanced understanding
of it. Right.
Oh yeah, I really don't give a [ __ ]
about the novelty of the thing or
anything arch. Like I just want this
thing to be implemented in a way that is
stable. Having thoroughly explored the
design space and coming to the
conclusion that this is either the best
thing or like the best thing that we can
realistically test uh in the space
as a starting point and that will work
and not have dumb edge cases.
good state coverage. Uh, I already have
a plan for that arch. That one's way
easier.
That one is literally just going to be
add high uncertainty states. Like set
some M's to high uncertainty states.
That's it. Done.
One of my mentors point out getting
scooped by someone. Yeah, but the thing
is like I no longer care about that
[ __ ] right? Like I'm not an academic. I
don't publish. Like the only thing I
care about is that we have like stable
good RL that works broadly and that lets
us solve very very hard problems that we
were not able to solve before.
Like I'll get pissed off um if like I
get if I have if I end up copying like
very close to something that is by
somebody I who I know is a big [ __ ]
but that's just me being petty.
And so far that hasn't happened.
The one time I thought that was going to
happen, it turned out that the uh the
paper was complete [ __ ]
But do remind me for when I'm writing
the article that I should um I'll
mention that one. Also, I'll mention Go
Explore. I'll mention Ryan's Thing. I'll
mention uh the tree searchy paper maybe.
I'm not really doing any tree searchy
things, honestly. I think the biggest
inspiration is just the original Go
Explore. Maybe Ryan's thing.
Ryan has a thing that's still in flux.
But the only thing I'll say is we came
up with at least one core similar idea.
What if my competition is watching? What
competition?
my competitors are death, ignorance, and
the madness of men.
I don't really wish I had competition.
Like, if I did have compet if there were
people that were competently doing this
stuff, I wouldn't be doing it. I'd be
doing some other thing that I find where
it's like, "Wow, I can make it 10,000x
better on my own."
Like, there are very, very many places
where things are just being done so
poorly that you can make them 10,000x
better. It's not the case that the world
is full of mature solutions to
everything where you can only ever make
incremental progress.
It's it's just not true.
Ryan Matt.
Yeah, Ryan's cool. I actually just saw
him. Uh I just saw him in SF the other
day
and in Palo Alto.
We had lots of margaritas. was good.
That's pretty funny.
Well, I'm looking at this and we're
definitely going to be able to have this
working if it's already this reasonable.
You can't just set up dominoes for me.
I'm the type that will always knock them
down.
So 11 with horribly broken code. Let's
see if we get more than 11 with not
horribly broken code.
uh with CL segment buffer. Yeah. So it's
going to the algorithm is a little
simpler now. So, it's just the simple
version of it is just keep um you're
going to keep the highest episode return
full trajectory that you've seen so far
for like end different environments or
seeds or whatever.
This is one of the consequences of
typing crap into codecs instead of doing
real engineering.
I'm tired. It's been three and a half
weeks. Whatever. We'll fix it. We'll
minify the diff and then I'll if I can
get the result then I will next week I
will manually like make it not suck.
What we learn overall segments
reward. No, no, no. So Ethan, you just
you have these segies
and then some of the M's just get to
sample anywhere in that trajectory. So
basically you have your best n solves or
whatever
and then you can start anywhere within
those. So the idea is that if you get
you're going to have the best segment is
going to be lucky, right? Or the best
episode's going to be lucky.
It just on average it will be.
And then uh you have some M's that get
to start from anywhere in that lucky
solve. So they get access to higher
quality data. It's still fully on
policy. It's a super simple algorithm.
It's robust in a whole bunch of ways the
other one wasn't. It's kind of dumb,
honestly, but this should work just
fine. Also, that was a solve right
there. So, before this thing crashed,
that just solved. So, even this horribly
broken version of this just solved. Um,
and that logging should be correct as
well. So, I'm sure that once we fix
this, this will work.
MCTS
MCTS. I'm not familiar with that. Seed
can't appear once.
Yeah. So, Arch, you just select like end
seeds at the start.
For things that have a ton of different
seeds, yeah, there's probably a better
way to do it. Um, but for now this will
be fine.
Yeah. So this is a solve here, right?
This is that's a full solve in one bill
steps. So this is considered a good
result even though it's completely
broken.
So I'm sure that once we fix all this
stuff up, we'll be fine.
The fact that we get any signs of life
this early is very good.
Hey, Jess. Uh, we have a horribly broken
version of the new algorithm already
working.
So, this will be fine. It'll work.
blah blah blah blah blah. Figure out why
this thing is broken.
Yeah, if I'm a man of the people, then
you need be you need better people
because I hate people.
But then again, there's a company uh
called Enthropic
that is uh
doing rather misanthropic things.
So,
See, these don't get enough views. Like,
we get a million views on all the other
things, but then the ones that actually
are like, "Hey, we also do professional
work. We build state-of-the-art RL Sims,
and it's rather affordable for big
companies.
You could have your team spend $10
million internally trying to do this, or
you could pay us a couple hundredk.
Oh yeah, this thing is um
I actually need to read all these
threads at some point because we
actually have stuff in the optimizer
where this is applicable.
All right, I'm going to go use the
restroom while this thing builds or
finds uh the bug and uh depending on how
long this takes, maybe go get myself my
protein shake. I'll be back in a couple
minutes. Anybody heading out, Star
Puffer before you do the repo on GitHub.
It helps a lot. Be right back.
This is a very stupid week, so we're
going to be stupid, too. This is 50
grams of unflavored protein powder,
hopefully not expired. Um, and a
tablespoon of cocoa powder with water.
We're going to see how awful this is in
a martini shaker, no less.
Three out of 10. Would not recommend,
but not as bad as I thought.
The faith doesn't lie.
Yep.
I think that what's happened in the last
couple weeks, honestly, I think the
reason I've just felt so awful is um so
I've been doing this pretty heavy cut,
like probably thousand calorie a day
cut. Um, that's not the bad part. That's
normally pretty easy for me. I think I
managed to cut way too much protein out
of my diet in the process. Um, normally
when I do the heavy cuts, I have protein
shakes and for whatever reason, I just
haven't been doing it.
You can see the difference already
though. Like literally go just tab back
on YouTube like four weeks of streams.
You can tell the difference
protein shake. Is that a new sweep
algorithm?
new algorithm for potentially fixing me.
Though, honestly, I think that the most
likely explanation is I've just gotten
bored in the last few weeks because
typing [ __ ] into codeex is a really
stupid workflow.
It is moderately efficient, if
incredibly frustrating for this type of
work, I suppose. Um,
but I will be very happy to be done with
this crap and like back to editing
things.
Oh yeah, if anybody's interested in
doing like some actually hard research,
um, improvements to protein are really
useful for puffer. Like really useful.
And I it's pretty much just the base
algorithm plus a bunch of heristics
right now. Um there's probably a lot of
room for improvement.
What you pretty much would do for
protein to improve it is like you just
take breakout which sweeps pretty fast
and maybe like cartpole or whatevers cuz
they sweep pretty fast and you'd
evaluate like the results and the
frontiers that you get from different
sweeps, how many experiments it takes to
fill out the frontier. And then once
you've dev something that you think is
better, then you would use a different
env to try it out. Right? So the the
test would be a sweep on an environment
Uh, yeah, you should be on Linux,
though. This is an old desktop. Like, I
don't even know. This is like a It's
It's not that old. It has a 3080 in it.
I built this thing a long time ago. And
uh it has a bunch of old crap on it that
I don't know if I need or not, and I
just haven't felt like reinstalling it.
And insert other excuses. In Maryland,
my main work setup is Abuntu. And I'm
not actually running anything on Windows
here. If you notice, like this is SH.
This is sshed into my Linux box. This
one's sshed into Linux box.
See, this is why I really should just
have my ideal work set up because people
see me typing [ __ ] into codecs all day
and they see me on stupid Windows and
they think, "Wow, that's how I should be
doing work." It's like, "No, no, you
shouldn't
Let me go grab
supposed to order something from Amazon.
Copy.
Hang on.
This is such a stupidly simple
algorithm.
There are a couple little details that
mattered though.
I guess like I'm happy that I know that
there isn't something obvious that you
can do that's more sophisticated with
advantage.
Nope. We do everything but LLMs very
intentionally.
No transformers, not too many prim. So,
um, if somebody came up with a
formulation of transformers that made
sense for RL, like sure, they'd be very
small. Small transformers are very, very
difficult to make hardware efficient.
And um in RL specifically, you have to
run the inference mode in order to
collect your data, which is really
really slow.
So RNN's tend to be better for RL.
Specifically with the latest update,
linear recurrences are amazing because
they're efficient for inference and
they're efficient for training on
relatively short sequences, which is
what we have.
So I mean it's possible somebody comes
up with a transformer thing that's
better compute matched but it would be
very difficult because of um the way
data is collected in RL
like I'd believe that you could get a
better transformer at say a million
parameters. I believe you could get a
better transformer for training time but
I think you just die on the inference
hill.
Like in normal um normal language
modeling research, right? They spend all
the compute on pre-training
which is parallel mode and then they
have to have a separate inference stack
for consumers.
But they can batch all that stuff.
It's not seek to seek though with RL,
right? Like
it RL is not a seek to seek problem.
RL is converting OBS plus any historical
information you have into actions.
I guess you can view that as seek to
seek but like
it really it's not quite seek to seek
like you can look at a decision
transformer that is seek to seek that's
like the closest thing that you'll find
but the thing is that is for offline RL
and a better word for offline RL is not
RL it's just supervised learning so the
inference mode specifically
that makes it tricky
no It's so seek to seek is not the thing
is the RL objective is not it's not a
seek to seek problem right
like would you consider
hang on let me think
would you okay if every single action
the LLM takes is a tool call right would
you consider that seek to seek it's not
really seek to seek cuz the output is
not like you need to see the output of a
tool call and then make a new decision.
It's not seek to seek
like a seek to seek implies that you
have a sequence and then based on that
you can output the entire other
sequence, right? And that's not the case
here.
Breakout has been swept. It swept on
five uh on 40 already
changed on 50
and 50 is not good for me. Yeah. So um
cuz 50 is not a stable release, right?
50 is like our crazy dev branch. Um I
think I might have messed with it.
So I like just use 40. 40 is the latest
public release
cuz you were doing you were doing like
entropy stuff, right? That doesn't have
anything to do with state sets. I don't
know why you would use 50.
Like when we have dev branches, right?
Like the next dev branch is not a stable
nightly release. That's not how Puffer
works. The next dev branch is whatever
absolutely insane things I'm currently
working on, which will eventually become
a stable release.
Also, the 50 algorithm is getting
completely rewritten right now.
So, you can expect that there's going to
be some like crappy 50 branch that works
and then uh it's going to slowly get
refactored into an actually good 50
branch by hand that's stable and works.
All this stuff that's on the side here,
this is just automated dumb debugging
of bugs written by the dumb LLM.
Um we're going to get a version of this
that solves so bond stably
and then it's we're going to minimize uh
the difference between this and 50 and
then I'm going to manually
like fix the implementation.
Good growth this weekend at least or
this week. We're almost to 30K follows.
I want to look into making 40 work on
AMD.
Ah,
yeah.
Oh, were you the one that submitted the
patch for that?
The AMD support thing is rough. If there
were like a sufficiently clean way to do
it.
It's like you can't even get AMD GPUs on
vast. So, it's basically just for people
with AMD laptop GPUs, at which point you
can rent like you can rent a GPU for um
10 cents an hour. I do think that we
should have a better CPU mode where like
you can run policies trained on Puffer 4
or five on CPU more easily.
I'd like to have that.
It's just tough otherwise.
Boston Uni guy went well working
something he claims to beat up by RL a
lot.
Yeah. If it make if the thing they have
makes any sense. Sure. It seemed like
very very theoryheavy stuff.
All right, let's see if they fixed it. I
doubt it is, but we'll see.
Cleaned up the PR for AMD GPU support.
Okay, in that case, if it's actually
like reasonable,
I will consider that.
If I have level 15 solves, what's the
next M to try to check if it
generalizes?
Uh, longer term, it would be the test
end we're going to mostly use will be
like 2048,
probably Vo's inferno environment.
Um,
and probably like the like the bigger
mazes as well.
It's unstable though.
Little unstable with these hypers.
We'll have to reweep it.
Yeah, that's fully solved in 90 seconds.
Look at that. That's fully solved in 90
seconds.
That's level 15, boys.
Um, unless this thing is cheated domain
knowledge and we are good.
We can actually
tighten total time steps because we're
not a kneeling right if we give it a 400
mil budget.
I'll check it. I'll actually give you
feedback on that since you've put effort
in.
I'm not saying no to AMD GPU support.
I'm saying no to adding substantial
complexity in order to support AMD. So
if you can support AMD without adding
substantial complexity that's good
boycott.
Yeah. So init the tweet that I made like
obviously you're not going to have
everybody boycott anthropic. That's not
the [ __ ] point. Um, the point is if
specifically all the AI researchers say,
"Well, you're gimping your models for AI
research, so we're not going to use your
models." That will be enough on its own
to um to make them trail Open AI on all
the stuff that matters. So, you know,
maybe they'll still end up being like a
consumer play thing where they make the
shitty AI for everybody, but they're not
going to be uh having the best models
if the like if AI researchers stop using
their stuff. They just lose such a big
source of public feedback.
And that's actually practical.
Like, why are you using the models? They
clearly are don't want you to use the
models for AI research.
That's it.
It doesn't require corporations to cut
spending at all. That's the thing.
Like if their models just get worse or
like aren't or like don't get better and
cheaper than the competitors, they'll
lose out anyways.
Okay. So, there is some noise here.
We'll give it 500 mil.
No, my hundred like my hundred bucks or
whatever doesn't matter at all. If
anything, they lose money on me using
that their thing from a code perspective
like a from a a token perspective,
right? It's the feedback that they lose.
Um, well, they're currently training
their models. So, their key thing at the
moment is using their AI to improve
their own AI. and they're currently
training their models on my RL code that
I have spent thousands of hours on. And
they're not even letting me use their
models in order to do my AI with.
And they're justifying this as that this
is them being the good guys being
responsible and safe
more than anything.
Not really, Eton. They all swap
employees back and forth every other
month. Anyways,
the uh the talent density at these
places is nowhere near as high as it
used to be. Like they got plenty of
idiots working for them. There's plenty
of smart people, but plenty of idiots as
well.
Oh, yeah. Obviously, like they have
Well, they probably mostly have the same
data at this point anyways, but I don't
know. They do have a bunch of data that
they've collected. I'm sure
they spend tons of money on that.
Well, that's just the time cut off,
though.
Why is SpaceX AI losing?
Um, because I don't think Elon's put in
the amount of time required to deeply
understand AI to make sure he's actually
hiring like smart people.
I mean, I said from the original tech
stack, right? The original tech stack
that they said that they were building
on was completely stupid.
It was Jack's TypeScript and Rust.
That's the I'm an idiot tech stack.
I actually I remember saying at the time
that like, yeah, let me know when one of
these labs says that their tech stack is
C and CUDA, then I'll pay attention. And
uh the problem is that in the meantime,
the models kind of got to the point
where now them saying that they're doing
all C and CUDA probably means that they
have the same idiots vibe coding the
entire thing, not like actual good
low-level systems people who know what
they're doing.
So, I completely believe that they could
do well. They have plenty of resources.
Um, the engineering management is
actually quite good from what I've
heard. It's just like, yeah, the lack of
knowledge to actually differentiate the
quality of people that they're hiring.
They get like a lot of shills and grifty
types that are super like, oh yeah,
we're going to shove everything, but
actually don't know what they're doing.
I love the enthusiasm, but it's got to
be tempered with actual knowledge.
Well, you need people that are not like
crayon eatingly glue sniffingly stupid,
right?
Like a lot of this stuff isn't rocket
science. The rocket science is harder.
That actually mean like requires you to
know some math.
But for whatever reason, programming is
just the most nerd snipe thing ever,
where people just do it incredibly
stupidly.
Chinese and these models will eventually
catch up.
Nvidia have smart people.
Well, I don't think Nvidia cares that
much. 810. I think that they're happy if
people buy their GPUs.
Like if anything, all the other
companies are losing money and Nvidia is
just making all the money, right?
Well, each like the thing is, okay, is
their B model even better now? I maybe,
but the the big labs just leaprog each
other every other month, and they also
swap employees back and forth every
other month. Anyways,
it's very SF. The whole thing is just
one big orgy. Okay.
Well, I mean the goal like my suggestion
to AI researchers who aren't happy with
this is to just stop using their models
and enough if enough of them do then
they'll fall behind.
Uh, Jess, non-competes are uninforceable
in California.
Yeah, I think Carpathy just you would
have thought he would have made enough
money from um Tesla. Maybe not. I don't
know.
I'm uh I'm a bit concerned.
He is kind of fitting the model I have
of um there are a bunch of people in SF
who used to be very smart and then just
did way too much acid
and I'm kind of getting those vibes like
a few too many trips to Burning Man kind
of a thing.
I got to say though for like Carpathy's
old work that he's done I have nothing
but respect for him. He had some of the
best uh the best like blogs and writing
on
a lot a lot of basics in the field. Um
arguably his work probably inspired a
lot of stuff with clean RL. Um I mean I
knew him back when he was a PhD student
very briefly and he was very smart back
then. Very quirky but very smart. um
know even some of his more recent stuff
before all the vibe Cody things with um
his like small LLM code bases been
tremendously useful arguably contributed
to development of Muon.
So tremendous tremendous amount of work.
That's actually pretty impressive
though, Piggy, that you're still getting
um 14
I do think that the advantage base stuff
is probably dead.
Yeah, Jess, the uh the nano GPT
speedruns, right, were a major thing.
White. Actually, I don't know if it was
that or CR was the Muan originally, but
arguably it's definitely contributed to
the verification of it for sure.
Um,
I I actually don't know what I like I've
heard some rumors, but
I hope I doing stuff that's better than
the rumors say. We'll see.
You might Okay, I will say this. There
might be a way to use it to sample from
the uh the good segments that you have,
but I don't see any way to keep it
fresh, right? Like, how do you have a
fresh advantage estimate over the
segment? I don't or over the episode. I
don't think you can.
You could train like a stateonly value
model maybe or maybe you could measure
like the difference between the value
function of the old policy and the new
policy. Like there might be something
you can do there.
If anybody wants to experiment with that
by all means but I think this really
really dumb version that I have here
will at least work. What do I mean fresh
advantage is an on policy estimate. The
advantage is it's based on from the
current state what like following the
current policy from the current state.
I didn't nerd snipe myself with the
advantage duff. It was a pretty subtle
the reason for failure was quite subtle.
And I guarantee you if I just took this
problem and phrased it without the
knowledge I have now and I didn't wait
it at all like probably none of the best
researchers out there would have caught
the mistake.
I actually I floated this idea to many
people and they all thought it sounded
like a great idea. So
yeah, the current approach is not using
advantage. The current explo approach is
more go explory in the sense that it is
about uh it's about refining
trajectories.
So like just finding and refining
trajectories and then using the the key
difference is that unlike go explore
which just finds the trajectories, we
use the trajectories to learn from.
And it's still all nice on policy RL.
So no like nothing screwy. It's very
nice.
Yeah, just the sources aren't super
reliable, so it's kind of meh.
Actually, are you allowed like let's say
that you have a secret project at a
company? Are you allowed to tell your
employees that they can say that they're
working on like some completely other
thing?
Could you just decide, oh yeah, you
know, tell everybody that we're working
on qu like we're working on solving
quantum physics with AI.
It's still off Paul. Yeah, exactly. E10.
That's the key problem with it.
I did not check Twitter for 10 minutes
and I have 20 notifications.
Hey, there you go. So, I guess that's
public now since he's made it public. We
did uh animation work for these guys. It
was one of our first contracts.
Yeah, they did. Um, it's like physically
grounded animation. So, they had a bunch
of noisy animation data that we needed
to run through a sim, do RL on, um,
clean it up with RL by physically
constraining it in the sim.
It was one of our first contracts.
From what I've seen, they're doing
pretty well. Now,
that was a really tough one actually
because we got stuck working with this
like awful awful existing robotic stack.
Not theirs, like the public one.
95 herblore.
Uh yeah, we got working on the like this
awful awful RL stack.
They got a real deal on the pricing cuz
I did not realize what we were signing
up Four.
Oh, okay. This is targeted at him, not
me. Cool.
This is LM crap, isn't it? Lovely.
Um,
I'm in a stupid mood today. I do stupid
things.
I'm not always required to actually be
funny. Sometimes I can just be dumb.
How was Daario as a person during your
open AI days?
What
was he there when I was there? I don't
think so.
I was there in um
what like 2018 I think. 2017 2018.
Yeah, I think this was before the this
was before the anthropic schism. The
anthropic schism was like two years
later almost. First year of my PhD maybe
2016.
Oh, then I was definitely there.
Well, I guess he just either wasn't
there in person or was not memorable
because this is the first I'm hearing of
it.
I remember um
Alec Radford.
Uh he was awesome. Ilia, of course. I
talked to Schulman a couple times,
obviously. Philip and such. Um there
were a couple interns that were super
cool. The Dota team was [ __ ] awesome,
though I didn't know many of them
personally.
Talked to Greg Brockman a couple of
times, though. I didn't really interact
with him as much as I like observed him
writing code with the team, which was
pretty cool.
In my mind, it was mo like Alec stuff
was really the big contribution.
Alec was really awesome.
He was just a swell guy as well.
Super nice guy, super focused, really
sharp,
terrible engineer, but
didn't really matter.
At least he didn't he would just throw
away all of his code every single new
project anyways. So he just wouldn't
accumulate tech debt because he wouldn't
accumulate code.
It was like it was really funny in some
sense cuz it's a very very effective way
of like of working around not being a
good engineer is to just throw away your
code very often.
I only realized this in retrospect, but
like that's kind of the best thing you
can do if you're just not a good
programmer.
You can only make so much of a mess
every couple months, right?
All right,
let's see how much code this thing just
deleted. We're not doing the manual
cleanups today, but I figure this is a
decent start. I don't have my watch.
What time is it?
Oh crap, it's already three.
It should get 15. If it doesn't, it
changes to the determinism.
When you're wrapping up stream, I don't
know. when I feel like it.
Okay. Told Spencer we solved.
I remember Mistl. No, they're still
around. They're just doing AI for
Europe.
Actually, one of my good friends went
there and who was a very good engineer.
They're probably doing fine.
you know, they're going to make European
compliant models for Europe or whatever.
That's good. You just found like a nice
theorist in
I don't have any problem with theorists.
I only have problem with theorists that
are like, you know, super uppidity about
the mathematical purity of their stuff
and just do not see the value of
empirical work at all,
But then again, I'm negative about most
people, so take that for what it's
worth.
What was that? Uh, with gym equipment,
American flag. That's in Maryland.
That's on my family's farm. I spend most
of my year there. It's my favorite
place. It's so nice.
Like I practically can't get a coffee
here without hearing like, "Oh, agent
this, agent that, [ __ ] [ __ ]
whatever."
Did I make puffer four here? Four there.
Uh, a good chunk of it. Yeah, puffer 4
was a very long update. That was that
was eight months, man.
I think once I have the full algorithm
fixed,
I'm probably going to step back for a
little bit and like actually get myself
in better shape
cuz I mean I just I fried myself so much
on puffer 4. Like I've been able to do
some good work since then,
but like holy hell was that. Like four
was just a lot.
I'd like to just chill and do some CUDA,
learn some more stuff, figure out what
problems we solve.
upper six.
Did I say six before the end of the
year?
I know I said five like end of summer.
Yeah, it would be six end of year. It
depends. I don't actually have the plans
for six yet. what to put in it.
I guess though we do have we do know the
last algorithmic thing at this point
that we have to do and it's not that
card.
state coverage. Yeah, Jess. I don't
think that's hard though.
I think if I'm going to get this cleaned
up first, but once I get that cleaned
up, I wouldn't be surprised. That's like
works in codeex in a day, takes me two
days to rewrite it cleanly.
We already have a collab that's like
worked on the core algo for
buff for 600k stars. That would be very
nice.
That would be very nice.
I mean, I do honestly think it is going
to be the type of thing where like
I think it's going to be the type of
thing where like everybody just goes,
"What?" Like, we can solve everything. I
mean, you saw the stupid pendulum thing,
how much that blew up. Like, it's a
really cool demo, but realistically, I
mean, it's basically just bolted on to
Puffer 4 and the core algorithm is doing
most of the work there. Like there are a
couple details you have to get right
obviously you have to sweep it but like
a lot of that is just coming from core
capabilities. It's going to be the type
of thing where like you know in a
version or two uh the core capabilities
are going to be such that you can just
solve problems that people are spending
tens of millions of dollars on and
everybody's going to go what where did
this come out of from nowhere but it's
clearly there already like most of the
problems that are just very very tricky
or whatever are actually easier to solve
than soabon if you don't hack domain
knowledge into it
like we fixed the problem that RL used
to have where [ __ ] was super brittle and
it only ever worked on one benchmark.
So, it's going to seem like it just out
of nowhere it solves everything. But, I
mean, anybody who's been watching the
streams can kind of see the writing on
the wall already.
Like, you don't have to believe in
exponential capabilities increase. You
basically just have to believe in like
the like pace of progress that we're
going at now, considering continuing
linearly, which it has been.
And like it's you don't even have to do
that in the abstract sense. You
basically have to think that we can
solve the one or two other remaining
limitations with our uh our core
algorithm and then we can like ablate
out some of the other little failure
cases and maybe optimize a little bit
more and we're done.
It's a couple algorithmic quirks that
cause like pathological failure cases
and then after that it's just like PF.
Yeah, the trust the exponential thing is
kind of a meme because like you can't
actually explain how you're going to
accomplish the things that you say.
Um,
but I can. it basically it's just that
we're improving bench we're improving
progress on a bunch of benchmarks that
look simple that if you understand RL
are not simple at all from first
principles we have perfect transfer from
there onto other tasks and we've been
using this exact set of tools to solve
real problems in industry
and like most of them are easier to
solve than our benchmarks
that's pretty much
That is 20,000 potions made
90 to 95 in the last two days.
our stuff at the moment is combining
stuff from lit for the most part, but
it's like pretty far-flung stuff, Right.
So like Puffer 4, the architecture was
two very very distant things applied to
a completely new domain.
The engineering was novel
and then in this case it is like go
explore
combined with very very different
engineering
and then also applied in like a very
novel way.
papers. Um, it's actually just more
stuff from Go Explore and uh, well, two
other small things. R&D to start with,
though I hate R&D. And then an
improvement thereafter of it.
I'll be right back. I use a restroom.
And uh, then we will we'll close this
out soonish. I want to get this down to
like
I want to have everything done for the
today that does not require me to look
at the code and then tomorrow we will do
the stuff that requires me to look at
the code. I'll be back.
Okay, that's all these stupid macros
going.
Oh yeah, we also have the recurrence
ablations to do.
It's a funny It's a funny little trip.
Look, this is the thing. I have this
just this very important flaw where uh
if you set up dominoes for me, if you
just set me up for a line, I'm going to
take the line. You know,
it's very very difficult for me to just
have dominoes and and not knock them
over. You know,
CS231N absolutely.
I don't know about the uh the recent
iterations of the course, but the
original lectures by Justin or Andre are
just as good now as they were back then.
Possibly even more useful now given that
the quality of a lot of information out
there has gotten so crap with all the
AI.
Yeah, my uh my RL guide is still up to
date. Like that still is good advice.
Yeah, some of the um the perf blips are
really weird.
I wonder if that's a logging fail.
Wait, the assignments are nowhere.
There's no way that you can't find this
tooth.
right
though, these are the solutions. You
probably just want the raw questions.
Is this by somebody on the actual course
or is this uh
Oh, a few people just under uploaded
their solutions, I guess, which you
should not be doing.
Presumably, they've uploaded some of
them, though officially
so that you're not going to just be
getting some random students code.
So, wait, that was not supposed to
change.
Yeah, that was not supposed to change
perf.
for recent versions.
I didn't find the answers.
Um, the problem sets are easy enough
that you can probably get an LLM to
one-shot them, but obviously that's not
the point.
Like, you won't like you won't learn
anything if you do that. They're
relatively short exercises
and they do teach you the fundamentals.
I think most problem sets are a waste of
time, but for the most part, those ones
were quite good.
Wait, this is I didn't realize that my
stupid [ __ ] you response is the top
reply on this stupid tweet.
It's [ __ ] hilarious.
Ryan Flurry did the like the classic
delete your account as well. Funny
stupid.
So I the thing that I think about the
nano GPT thing, right, is um
are you required to have multiple seeds
on this?
Hang on.
Is this multiple seeds at the very
least?
Doesn't look like it.
But where's their submission stuff?
Uh, no it's not.
Is there like no seed variance at all in
this problem.
I actually think just implement the
stupid thing and like optimize CUDA
would be super funny. No.
What did Daario do to you?
um I mean trained on my RL code that
I've spent many many thousands of hours
on and then told me that for my own good
I can't use my own like I can't use
their model that they trained on my AI
code to improve my AI code but they can
use it for their AI code and it's for my
own good so [ __ ] Um,
if they just came out and said like,
"Look, to maintain our competitive
advantage, uh, we're not letting people
use this for AI development anymore." I
would say, "Okay, fair play."
You know, I still wouldn't use their
stuff, but I'd be like, "Okay, fair
play.
But if you're going to tell me, "Oh,
it's for safety and whatever the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you."
Like you do with bio and chem and all
that, [ __ ] you.
Literally, the only reason that these
models will have um like the any ability
to reason about efficient RL is because
of the puffer codebase.
There's nothing out there remotely
comparable.
And in fact, if you check some of the
older models and ask them stuff around
Puffer, they just lie. Like they just
make up that a whole bunch of other RL
repos have these advanced techniques
implemented when there are literally no
other code bases in existence that have
this stuff.
You know, I'm fine with the copyright
fair use thing until they start nerfing
the capabilities to give themselves an
asymmetric advantage. I am fine with
like it being accepted that AI companies
can train on whatever they want, right?
spend a [ __ ] ton of money to create a
model off of it and then sell you back
the model, I'm actually fine with that.
But when you tell me you can't even use
it and you're just going to use it for
your own internal development, [ __ ] you.
Somebody clip that. No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no. If we're going to do
this properly, it's like look, look,
look, look, look. It's a little warm up
here.
me.
All right, this is week three of really,
really stupid algorithm dev where I
don't actually get to edit real code.
Um,
this ends today. Tomorrow I get to edit
real code which will be
Very very nice.
possibly broke determinism.
I wouldn't be surprised.
We'll test that. Don't worry.
Well, we need our bitwise determinism.
H.
This is a very short budget by the way.
We know that we can solve this. Like I'm
the result is the result is already
secure. So don't worry about that guys.
These are super janky hypers. We can
super easily just sweep this. The result
is good.
What time is it?
All right, I'm going to give it 20 more
minutes because I want to be able to do
a couple things at 4
before my uh dinner at 5.
or is this
Oh no, this is not the clip. Okay. was
born in the USA.
Oh yeah, I forgot about that. That was
really funny if you think about it in
retrospect Now,
Hello. Okay, the mic's back.
Stupid camera drivers, man.
Hang on. I'll fix the camera.
I can see when it goes down and I stop
talking, but
Does Sam even program? Does Dario even
program?
I think Daario might. I don't think Sam
does.
Realistically, I'm a much better
programmer than most of these companies
scientists and a uh a much better
um a much better scientist than most of
these companies engineers.
So,
I have depth but also a bit of breath.
I honestly think that the um like being
a really good systems dev is harder than
being a good like a good scientist
though. It is just a different kind of
hard sometimes.
Ilia Andre
Ilia like wasn't really a deep
programmer. I'm definitely I'm not I'm a
worse scientist than I for sure. I'm
probably a better programmer. Does he
like Well, I actually don't know to be
fair. I actually don't know what his
like own programming was. Um I don't
know how much like he contributed to the
end stuff of his like early of his early
work.
I actually don't know with Carpathy
either.
So Carpathy is
honestly a lot of the things I'm good at
are similar to the things that Carpathy
is good at.
Like I'm quite good at making things
simple,
making complex things simple and then
really really drilling down to the
source of stuff.
It unfortunately broke my best testing
feature for puffer, which is the um
non-determinism. So now I got to sit
here and do this.
throughput is much higher.
Well, nowadays nowadays he's kind of
just vibe coding [ __ ] isn't he?
like his throughput is actually very
low, isn't it? He kind of even when he
was doing um in his peak, right, he
would put out like a few really good
things a year.
He's joined Enthropic. Yeah, he's doing
whatever. But I'm trying to think what
was his like peak stuff. I think it was
before all the models got super good.
It was before the models got super good.
Um, or not super good, but I I should
say usable.
I never really looked at the original
like GPT2 stuff. Maybe then
cuz I think the low-level stuff that he
did was already viby.
Honestly, I put like I put car pathy
more in the bin of like the type of
stuff Costa has done.
He reads all the code.
That's not enough.
I mean, give some respect to Carpathy.
He's like genuinely responsible some for
some pretty amazing stuff.
Like, just consider him retired and call
it a day.
atomic but not ordered.
Yeah, that's the type of thing it would
be.
Think it would put us higher by two
minutes. Honestly,
there are a lot of good people I used to
know that I now I just think of them as
being retired. like they've completely
lost their edge, but I just I like think
of them as just being retired.
Sad thing is most of them are late 20s,
early 30s.
Yeah, I saw Andrew's retweet. We did
animation work for them.
Okay.
See if this is good.
I'm not going to ban Bad. I know he's
meing.
He's the He's got the procelite of the
puffer order title.
Ooh.
Hey, the hex maps look really cool,
don't they?
I like that. That's just pllin. This is
basically just pearling with hex maps in
the shader, right?
That's nice.
How's our verification going?
We'll see what this does. Maybe run it a
little longer. We'll see.
So much better having like indie game
devs on the timeline than
AI shells.
They just chill. They work on their game
for a bunch of years. They hope a few
people buy it.
It's nice.
All right. All right. So, we have to
make the run a little bit longer, but
this will be fine.
Why isn't Gary Tan on my timeline? Cuz
he's a [ __ ]
It's actually probably why I've never
liked the game. I'm so bad at it that
like I can't hit anything and I don't
even have the hit sound to tell me when
I have hit something.
Time is it?
Almost four. This is going to be the
last thing. We're going to make sure we
haven't completely giga broken
everything and then we will be on.
This is the type of stuff I'm interested
in, though not by trying to replace a
sim with a model, just trying to write
SIMs or sell subcellular stuff.
When will puffer lip solve disease?
I mean, that's on the top of the list.
Um realistically I will get to start
working on that when I deem that RL is
stable enough that um we are no longer
bottlenecked by the algorithm and it's
safe to majorly shift focus.
Like I don't want to be trying to solve
really hard problems in bio with RL
still being kind of janky. You know,
ideally we um we solve a bunch of stuff
in RL. We solve some easier applications
that are still worth a bunch of money so
we have plenty of funding without having
to deal with investors
and then we start doing some bio stuff.
I will say it's not guaranteed that we
start with bio stuff. I think we're
going to start with like my main
interests are in very lowle sim, right?
So like molecular level sim potentially.
Um it might be more realistic to do
stuff in material science to start with.
It might be fine that we do stuff in
bio. I'm not entirely sure yet.
I mean the thing I can guarantee you is
that it's very unlikely you're going to
see us just like tackling the same
problems everybody else do is doing with
a slightly different approach.
Whatever we do, we'll end up just
looking very different and out there.
Also, aging must be considered a a
disease.
It's just pure cope.
Um,
I think one of the strongest opinions I
hold is that you cannot be truly
considered intelligent if you think that
um if you think that aging is like good
or necessary.
It's like you think about this for two
seconds and it's obviously stupid.
There's just a really really hard cope
on that one.
Hey, Spencer.
Uh, hang on. Let me tell you.
Okay, very good. And, uh, I am at a
decent enough spot, man, that I can help
you. Uh, if you would like because I no
longer have a million things in my head.
Um, hang on. Let me let me give you the
quick update on this. So,
The quick update on this is now it is
what 700 lines 700 lines of code. Um
the new algorithm works. It's very very
simple. It's only tested on so we have
to test it on more places. It's all
codec garbage. I have to rewrite it
manually almost entirely, I'm sure. But
there's no longer a ton of details that
need to be maintained. Like it's a
simple algorithm.
Um,
I think that's pretty much the
situation. Yeah.
Uh, if you have religious reasons for
believing that spicy, then that's at
least respectable. There are a lot of
people who aren't even religious who
have like PhDs from top universities who
will insist this and it just [ __ ]
baffles me.
No, bet. We respect. No, we we don't do
that. All right. People can believe what
they want. Um that's fine.
Okay, this is good.
Let's see if this train's the same.
Yeah, we're not discussing that stuff on
stream.
The comment I made was completely
apolitical.
The way we keep it,
we focus on science here.
the only reason I made the comment on
anthropic stuff, right, is the one
exception I'm allowed on politics and
policy, right, is when it directly
affects like core AI and science
research. That's it. I've been pretty
damn good about sticking to that as
well.
So, obviously, gimping models for use in
AI
directly screws up our ability to do
science and stuff in the open, right?
And to be fair, we can do it without the
models anyways,
but it's still shitty.
I stuck this one on one bill
uh just so we guarantee that it should
solve if it doesn't get unstable.
I saw 14.
I think this is fine. We're going to do
one last thing before I call it for
today, just so I can launch a sweep,
though. Okay.
Yeah, I'm going to probably take an
extra 20, 30 minutes to do this.
Um, some of them are. It's like simple
CL arch if you look at the the latest
commits.
And I'm about to push all of them. I
just want to I want to make the
benchmark
scale to like 25 30 ends real quick.
That way we have something to push it
on.
It's going to be very noisy like to be
clear because this is just increasingly
sparse. So we expect it to be very
noisy. But I want to try something.
Yeah. Simple CL like 5.0- simple CL or
whatever.
benchmark meaning what m
wait what did you what is that in
relation to so I'm just taking all I'm
doing right now is the soabon env uh the
default settings right now it's 15 fixed
levels in ascending difficulty
Uh, I'm just making it so that it's like
more than 15 levels. We're going to keep
this the first 15 levels exactly what
they are. And uh, we're going to just
have it be more after that. That's all.
Obviously, this is not the only end
we're using. This is we're treating this
as our development environment.
in which we like test stuff on the
algorithm
and then once we have the algorithm done
then we're going to like sweep the
algorithm the new algorithm on all the
other ends.
So like incremental so is our dev end.
Uh no they're going to be fixed arch but
like we're basically just sorting. So
instead of it being the first 15 easiest
levels to solve, it'll be the first 30
easiest levels to solve.
Do you watch P? No, I don't really watch
um TV or movies
to be honest with you.
Physics engine
with plus metal.
Waiting for maps and then we'll have our
new benchmark.
Are humanoids and households a realistic
thing? I mean, maybe. But is that
seriously the most interesting thing you
can think of with AI is like
replacing the need for a housekeeper
with a piece of hardware that's like 20
30 grand?
Like really?
I mean, my version of the future where
AI is [ __ ] cool and solve stuff is
like we don't age and die of pres
preventable diseases and uh you know, we
have some cool sci-fi materials that I
don't know, let us like dick around in
space and stuff And uh you know we have
super efficient specialurpose
manufacturing hardware for everything
that makes everything dirt cheap.
Like that's my cool that's my version of
the future. That sounds way cooler to
me.
Do you transfer consciousness?
I don't [ __ ] know what consciousness
even is, if it exists. I don't think
anybody does. It's irrelevant, though.
of the spicy to what
responses
of which tweet?
Oh, what? You want me to plug puffer?
Like that's not a reasonable thing to
plug puffer in.
It is very funny that I think this is
still the top reply which is pretty
funny.
the whole consciousness debate is like a
complete [ __ ] nerd snipe. There's
probably some precise way to define and
measure it, but I haven't heard anything
reasonable and it's like irrelevant.
Like I'm not talking about digitizing
people or whatever. I mean literally
just like reverse processes associated
with aging, cure diseases.
Then the only deaths would be to
accidents
I don't think it's I don't even think
that's relevant at all, man. I really
don't think that matters that much.
it's not a PR thing. It's just a nerd
snipe. Like, people in SF get into very
long discussions about this crap that go
nowhere.
It's like the like the Batman slap meme
like you know to [ __ ] build
something. It's just that
Oh, you're probably right that they're
going to try that crap at some point.
The thing is I they'll actually believe
it as well.
Remember when that like Google engineer
went nuts over over that with like
GPT3.5
or something?
In retrospect, it's completely stupid,
right?
It's like, okay, you're clearly just
Nimbisil.
All right, we're not doing this whole
crap bet. Come on, science.
We actually made a pretty nice um
breakthrough today. as dumb as it was.
It's a really dumb algorithm, but it
seems like it works
and it really should work as Oh,
um
I mean the the simple description of it
which is like 80% correct is
just keep the highest episode return uh
just keep the highest
episode return trajectory
and then have some of the M start their
rollouts from random states along that
trajectory. That's literally it.
Okay, we'll have to do perf
improvements, but hopefully this is
decent.
Might be unstable. We're going to re
sweep.
some super janky game.
It's not Doom.
What is this?
80 mil steps is like
Oh, look at that. We've already passed
uh Look at that. Level 17 on there. It's
unstable.
Yeah, but that's mega that's mega soda.
That's mega soda. It gets very hard like
past 15 even.
All right, cool. I'm very happy with
this. Well, I don't sound happy because
typing [ __ ] into codeex all day is
[ __ ] brain dead. Um,
Let me just make sure that the sweep
setup is good because I want to have the
sweep going today.
Okay, we did this.
EPS pryo.
All fine.
I'm putting this to 0.12
even 25. I'm sick of value function
being jank.
I'm also sick of clip co being jank.
mini batch size.
Do I let it sweep the mini batch size? I
think I do, right?
But it doesn't get to sweep anything
else.
I think this is good, right?
Ah,
VF clip co.
Oh, this is going to give us an
outofbound sample, which is kind of
jank, right?
I'll go.
Released full open source as promise is
good.
Very dumb algorithm, but this is going
to solve a lot of stuff.
All right, there you go. Y'all can play
with this. Um, I'm expecting that this
will sort of like everything once we
have it cleaned up and fast.
This stuff is not optimized yet. This
needs to be made fast. There's a whole
bunch of things I need to do manually.
The code [ __ ] sucks, but this is at
least a result.
Um, for everyone who's been tuning in,
thank you very much. I'm exhausted.
Uh, mostly I'm exhausted from boredom
because typing [ __ ] into codeex is not
really real engineering and I want to do
some real engineering.
We'll do that starting probably
tomorrow. If you're interested in my
stuff, if you want to support me for
absolutely and utterly free, feed the
puff for a star on GitHub. He likes
stars. He's hungry. We're almost to 6K
here. Growth has been pretty great. We
need uh this ignore this number. This
number says 5999. You literally one star
is required. So that that star is you.
So go star it. Um other than that,
Discord if you want to get involved.
It's actually pretty easy to get started
building ends and such. Follow on X for
more reinforcement learning content.
And that's about it. I'm going to go get
some dinner. See you.